ce à quoi nous devons nous attaquer
c'est le séparatisme islamistes c'est un
projet conscient théorisé politico
religieux qui se concrétise par des
écarts répétés avec les valeurs de la
république qui se traduit souvent par la
constitution d'une contre société et
dont les manifestations sont la
déscolarisation des enfants le
développement de pratiques sportifs
culturels communautariser qui sont le
prétexte pour l'enseignement de principe
qui ne sont pas conformes aux lois de la
république
c'est d'endoctrinement et par celui ci
la négation de nos principes l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes la
dignité humaine le problème c'est cette
idéologie qui affirme que ces lois
propres sont supérieures à celles de la
république
l'islam est une religion qui vit une
crise aujourd'hui partout dans le monde
nous ne voyons pas que dans notre pays
c'est une crise profonde qui est lié à
des tensions entre des fondamentalismes
des projets justement religieux et
politiques qui on le voit dans toutes
les régions du monde conduisent à un
durcissement très fort y compris dans
des pays où l'islam est la religion
majoritaire regarder notre ami date
uneasy pour ne citer que cet exemple il
y a trente ans la situation était
radicalement différente dans
l'application de cette religion la
manière de la vivre et les tensions que
nous vivons dans notre société sont
présentes dans celle ci qui sans doute
l'une des plus éduqués développer d'âge
et donc il y à une crise de l'islam
partout qui est gangréné par ses formes
radicales par ces tentations radical et
par une aspiration à un jihad réinventer
qui est la destruction de l'autre mais
force est de constater qu'il y à un
islamisme radical qui conduit à nier les
lois de la république
qui conduit à banaliser la violence et
qui a conduit certains de nos citoyens
de nos enfants à choisir le pire ou à
considérer que le pire était devenu
naturel et donc à créer les conditions
de dérives politiques mais aussi de
dérive violente celle du terrorisme
islamiste
ce qui est aujourd'hui notre défi c'est
de lutter contre la dérive de certains
au nom de la religion en veillant à ce
que ne soient pas visés ceux qui veulent
croire en l'islam et sont pleinement
citoyens de notre république